[Music]
welcome back to careful boys it should
be noted that if you are a member of our
Discord um that means you're probably
also a patreon subscriber you're going
to eat that you're going to eat that
guacamole no we're not going to get that
guacamole oh wait there's some here I
forgot that I just capped it it's okay
we're not going to redo the
intro and uh if you guys are a member of
the Discord that means you can suggest
article or OTR ideas in which case our
friend Kazu has done just that Kaz Kazu
wants to know what's something nice you
did for somebody and then it
backfired M man a [__] ton of [__] let
Joe go
first then
Bart it's whoever's not here very simple
not so people moved on what do you
mean no you got anything recent that
like might happened nah oh wait you guys
anything ancient that you like to dig
up about six times before all right not
really nice right
so um at my store yeah we had a guy come
in when the when the workers are in the
front and they did a little sneak and
they grabbed some Beats by Dre oh and
then you know and then one of my
employees she was devastated she was
like damn I don't know what happened
someone took my headphones
so we we the reason why we know this is
cuz she thought someone in the store
like Employee Store and I was like no no
no I don't think anyone's that shady so
we looked in the camera and then we saw
the guy and then we showed it to her and
we're like damn that sucks she goes oh
that those headphones were so expensive
expensive yeah yeah and I said oh how
much is it and then she was like they're
like 300 I'm like what the [__] and I'm
like dude I feel bad I was like just
give me a link I'll buy it so I bought
it for her right that was nice cuz I was
and then she just started working with
us cuz I was like what a horrible way
and and then after that this girl would
be like hey guys um I'm going to take a
break her friends come hang out this
girl's out at the beach hanging out and
like with Beats by Dron like like while
the worker while the co-workers are just
like swamped pick up her [__] and then
they see her sharing on her stories
[__] hanging out at the beach with
their friends comes back several hours
later hours habitually
late always pulls this [__] out where
she's like oh I got to go to the
bathroom how long is the break supposed
to be like 15 minutes she's gone for
hours hours bro and then she did this
multiple times oh can you cover for me I
got go to bathroom I have to go so bad
and then she's like oh my friends are in
town so she just decides not to come
back to work and I'm like
dude what the [__] and everyone's just
mad they're like yo uh what the hell
like like how does she explain herself
like she doesn't she goes sorry yeah
you're right I lost track of time I was
having fun like she doesn't even lie I'm
like at least [__] lie please like
it's hard to pay attention with these
[__] headphones on you know the the
noise cancellation is so good hey you
have to turn it up a little bit I don't
regret buying her the headphones cuz I
feel like either way it's just [__] up
right that's fine but for me I'm just
thinking like I regret you buying her
headphones me to if I was if I was in
her shoes uhhuh I would have been so
like oh this is a sick ass workplace and
everyone just watches for each other and
whatever right and I'm all like and
obviously like I had to tell her like
you know that you got to go but oh oh
you fired her I guess so oh I
technicality technicalities you know but
some people are just sick [__] though I
just realized dude some people are just
[__] sick [__] and like you think
you would operate a certain way why why
is she a sick [__] cuz she [__] left
her post someone she left her La people
are [__] sick [__] Jeffrey dmer sick
[__] this girl sick [__] Joe hooked her
up imagine like if if I just started
working for a company and like let's say
someone broke into my I work at Radio
Shack or whatever someone broke into my
car stole stole something right I'm like
oh [__] Dam that's so [__] up the boss
I don't even know was like you know what
I'll pay for your window and nothing I'd
be like oh dude I'm going working for at
least 5 years that's [__] that move
that moved me that's crazy wow you would
to come in and be like oh dude this
happened my my TV got stolen
boss my gold bullion got stolen yeah so
I just realized like somebody jacked my
[__] ring many sick [__] out there
sick [__] took my ring yeah there's so
many sick [__] out there jerking off
with it or something but you know what I
I I think people just operate different
some people will will go and say I'll
never do that for another employee again
but for me I'm like I'm not going to let
this [__] face like change the way I
treat people right sick [__] sorry sick
twisted [__]
I'm not going to let that change the way
I'll just operate cuz it's like maybe I
just didn't do it for the right person
right person but sick [__] once I
realized Who the sick [__] are I start
I stop helping people especially sick
[__] as
much well I I wouldn't help a sick [__]
but I I I think
that I think that it's it's
actually worse for you that you allow
them to change how you treat people yeah
like you're genuinely like the way that
you are without cuz for me like for
example some people might take it as oh
you did that to uh make you know cuz you
want something out of it cuz you expect
something out of it right some sick [__]
[__] dude yeah but then I'm like well
let's say you're you're like a happy
Jolly kind person and and then you're
generous or whatever like some people
get jaded because of how many [__] sick
[__] they run into and then they stop
treating people that way so they
actually let them control you but then
if you've done it a lot and you
constantly get taken advantage of don't
you think you should maybe change how
you are a little well I don't think I'm
what you what's the word like I don't
think I'm passive and I get walked all
over what if you see on the camera at at
the job it's like you see this girl that
she keeps on getting on her phone during
office hours and you're you now know
that she's like a sleazy psychopath then
I kick the phone out of her hand he buys
our headphones yeah she's a [__]
cannibal no the the way that she didn't
even get she didn't even get headphones
stolen and I just buy her a pair yeah
know the way that I I think that I view
it is um you know like I view like my
relationships kind of like uh like my
circle right like my tightest circle is
of course me Gio and taica then who's
like outside of that who's outside of
that and it goes further and further and
further all the way till the most outer
ring is strangers oh most
no no no like the most outer ring is is
strangers right and I think when me and
Joe first got into business like we
always wanted to do what uh we wished
our old companies or jobs or whatever
had so I would extend the Family
treatment almost all the way out to
strangers oh right so like even people
so I would like that's why we would we
would bring everyone to our JK trips or
whatever and this we would apply this to
JK and barbell but over the years I
think because there's so many sick in
the world I started realizing maybe I
shouldn't treat someone I just hired for
a week like my mom you know and then I
would bring it back and bring it back
and bring it back so now I start now I
dial it back I'm like I'll I'll I'll
I'll keep my family for my family or my
close friends that's fair yeah that's
why he treats us like
strangers makes sense oh cuz my story
was there was a couple of a couple of
guys
um that I lent like 1,000 bucks too cuz
they were uh what is it called like
going through some of the craziest [__]
in their life at the time and they were
probably some of the two craziest that
jeopardized uh my business on the Barb
Brigade in oh no and one of them ended
up being uh on his last day he uh was
like threatening a lawsuit he was going
to beat up our gym manager was a chick
like it was it it ended really bad and I
was just like holy [__] you never you
just never would think when someone is
in deep [__] and uh they they need money
and then you're like here's here's 1,000
bucks I'm like you just pay me back
whenever you're comfortable and like
this is outside of business I'm not even
front I'm not even Fring your your
paycheck this is out of me and then but
sick [__] exist so like I'm just like
okay that's a good example of regretting
something that you've done nice to
someone so I'm like okay this guy I've
known him for like 8 months maybe I
shouldn't treat him like I've known him
for 20 years but ever did he ever have
anything about him that made you feel
comfortable to do that or is just a
principle that you had just I'm like oh
if you're with if you're in here you're
my family because he's already part of
that barbell like yeah it' just be like
okay you're damn anyone that's even in
my vicinity I'm like let me just pull
the family thing all the way to the end
and I started to realize maybe I
shouldn't treat everyone like family and
I start bring it back dialing it back ah
and after that particular moment was
there a heavy dial back with you
personally yeah like every single thing
um like my my own personal emotional
investment becomes okay it's it's the my
own circle gets Tighter and Tighter and
Tighter the trust has to tighten up yeah
the trust for sure yeah yeah I remember
somebody did something nice for me and
then I backfired it on them why don't Li
me like you backfired it on them yeah
it's the other way around we got a sick
[__] in here was a sick [__] dude sick
[__] Anthony once a sick [__] always a
sick like we set up a sick potluck and
you just say you can't show up like that
yeah that was pretty
heartbreaking that's not a backfire
that's more of a frontal fire okay I
felt like a backfire okay I was the one
who missed out okay oh all right you're
welcome Colleen anyways um so uh we
might have talked about it when Lawrence
was here there was a time where uh you
know back in like 2011 or whatever I
like got got laid off broke up me and my
girlfriend broke up and you know just
had like a super lowo right and then uh
he was working low recognize low he was
working at a Sushi Restaurant Lawrence
cow and then he was like yo I can get
you a job at this spot and I was like
all right dud I'm super down to waste
some tables because you know you get
cash on hand with tips and that'll help
you with your schedule flexibility if
you're I'm trying to pursue dance and
stuff but it was in linat and I lived in
bour park in OC so it was like a 50
minute drive if I wanted to get to work
so he's like dude he was living at noo
at the time with a bunch of our old
College homies and he's like dude you
can crash our spot right you know want
somebody opens the door but then you
overstay your welcome so I was like
crashing at the spot you and then next
thing you you know like we were hanging
out blah blah I get it thank you I'm
sorry I'm a sick [__] so you left her
toothbrush there freaking sick [__] what
the [__] I just had a go bag that was
always like in the car and stuff sick
[__] calling it a go back too even
sicker Fu so then iend boyfriend it got
to a point
where and I just didn't realize it got
to this point i' never been in that
position before too but it got to a
point where the housemates there was
like six people that lived there and
they had a meeting about me oh [__]
Lawrence was always cool about cuz
Lawrence was one of just coolest dudes
well he doesn't even wear underwear yes
that's true he's pretty cool man so he
was always super cool and I've been
living with Lawrence for like almost my
entire College you know what I mean so
it's like we just had that Dynamic and
half the guys that were in that house I
lived with them in college too but again
the difference is I was paying rent this
time I'm not paying rent and granted
there's like a Grace per where
everybody's cool with you because you're
getting back on your feet but then you
don't always know where that line is
until somebody says hey here's the line
yeah you know what I mean were you using
their toothbrush and everything not
their toothbrush that's were you like
Hey guys you're out of toilet paper like
what's the deal yeah can you guys buy
your toilet paper what's going on here
some it please come on who Pizza is this
yeah but yeah there was definitely a
moment where they had a meeting about it
and then they had to tell me and I was
like oh [__] my bad I think Lawrence
Lawrence just told me he's like hey dude
um
so uh my bad but like we had like a
meeting about like you staying over too
much and stuff and you know since you're
like not paying rent I was like oh but
you know when when once they told me
yeah it's so clear but why but why is
that [__] I've been you though you're
not a sick [__] cuz you to you take it
the reasonable way versus man [__] them
yeah so I only snuck back in at like
3:00 a.m. and then slept and woke up at
600 and left yeah the people in these
stories would be like yo everybody's
against me yeah pie of [__] so true yeah
uh learn from my sick [__] not my story
but was it MLK no they they accepted
100% it was weird it was the first time
I I had to let someone go then they
totally agreed with me who's this my
story oh the one okay you said not my
story you're about to tell another story
oh no so in your I I want to ask whose
story is it so in your story right it's
supposed to backfire on the people that
gave you something and make them regret
it how did they regret it no they did
cuz there was a moment where they opened
their house the welome
stay
there weeks turned into 3 months or
whatever I see I see I see I thought it
was like something like you [__] did
something so bad to them that it was
like he got back but there the
difference is like when everybody is
there paying rent and you're the one guy
who's basically using the same fre
loader Anthony yeah but I learned I
don't think that's fool sick [__] though
no I appreciate that no that's not sick
[__] at all cuz you didn't really like
you're till this day you're grateful and
you guys are all friends we are still
you make a video goes why I left the
apartment yeah that's true you know so
it's different that one's kind of
different that's pretty funny man dude
you should make a video of why you left
the apartment I told you guys my story
which is just that like I got covered in
blue pain and like I had I you know I
did I had to humiliate myself and I
regretted it as soon as I got there but
I still did it I did what I said I was
you mean the Avatar when you did the
Avatar one not that one a different time
we got covered in blue it's a good story
though because it it does show how much
of a riter you are that like you're
already here you said you would do it
can you tell the story again no I'm good
no we we have a link we have a long
story is that link in the description
below no no no I'm sure cool and if it's
not can somebody comment it in so I can
reference that again dude there was a
there was a really like sad one that
that I got into with uh this friend of
mine who was like a a K-pop like rapper
or something and um he had been asking
me for the longest time like uh at the
time I was living with red fu he was
like yo it's been my dream to like um
work with lmf or something like like let
me know A Dream yeah and then like he
showed me his vision board and like lmf
was on it or some [__] I was like that's
pretty tight and then he just would hang
out a lot he would come around a ton and
then um and I thought we were like
friends you know and then like um at one
point he was like yo do you think like
um since I'm I'm already going to be at
the house for this party he's like do
you think red fu is down to like film
this like really quick video where he
just like introduces uh he like does
this little skit I'll just have
everybody there all he has to do is like
sit there and just like read this paper
real quick I was like yeah I'll ask him
and then um like Fu usually trusts
everything that I'm like I suggest him
cuz he knows that I've already vetted it
and then in this situation I was like
yeah he's my friend I don't think it'd
be anything weird like just all you got
to do is read this script real fast and
the script was just like a like kind of
like a a skit where he's like a
newscaster and he's like introducing
this song so like oh he's probably going
to put as a bumper for his like new
track or whatever he was like yeah I'll
do it for your homie so then he does it
and then um after he does that we later
on see a release of the track and it
says featuring red Fu as if he was a
musician yes and then uh wait but all he
did was like announce it all he did was
like was it ladies and gentlemen the
best K-pop Star in the whole world it
was sort of oh it wasn't like sounds
like a feature yeah yeah yeah yeah so
with a feature if for people that you
know don't know the music stuff a
feature costs a lot of money it's a lot
and it's a lot of negotiations a lot of
paperwork it's a lot of points it's like
you got to do a lot of stuff for that
but he basically just like sneakily got
it and not only that but the song itself
premiered on [__] PornHub why because
at at this time PornHub was trying to
expand into music as a KP so they were
no they were like and the song was F the
Jew they were featuring red food they
were like signing um
Fu they were signing like certain music
artists and then to just have like a
separate thing and then so like I
remember like Fu telling me like hey man
like I really took your word on it but
now it's like I can't even I would want
to be associated with por of music and I
felt so bad and it when did that come
out um it was just like a little blip on
the thing it wasn't like a popular thing
and it really was just like f was just
in the music video as an intro thing
which we already kind of knew that would
probably happen but you're not supposed
to put it on the audio like listing on
like Spotify and things like that that's
not part of a title you're allowed to do
yeah you just can't do that but um but
yeah that's that was the dirtiest thing
and and I didn't even see that dude
again after that he like never going to
like autotune his his voice and to like
say can you read this like lyrics real
quick and then he just reads it and then
like and it becomes a song and it's an
actual feature [__] what I love about
this guy too is he probably like he's
probably like tons friends was like yeah
you know me and red we were talking
about this [__] like me and fu yeah
we're figuring it out yeah probably
that's that's the sad part is like he he
was so like active and like hanging out
and like knowing about my whole life and
[__] and then after he got that like I
hardly ever saw him he used you see
that's a sick [__] right there doesn't
normally happen to me cuz I'm usually
pretty good at like you know knowing
when that's going on because I've lived
in La my whole life but then for some
reason like I just really was like oh I
want to help this dude out you know
what's pretty funny about that producer
talk where they like [__] Brown knows
the [__] out of you for like one hour
and then they ask you what they want
that actually pisses me off what do you
mean I that pisses you off yeah that
pisses me off cuz I'm like you wasted
one hour of my time telling me how great
I am just so you can ask this question
oh and I'm like you wasted time like I
already know how [__] dope I am just
tell me like ask me the question I'll
give you whatever you want and then next
time I want something well next time if
I want something you owe me and that's
it don't waste my time what if that guy
has nothing to offer they will when
Hannah's telling you they got something
everybody's got a but
hole everyone's got lips bro what when
Hannah's telling you like how dope you
are you're like I already know how dope
I am just get to the point
yeah stop showering me with love and
[__] dud tell me what you want no dude D
be like this guy I know exactly what
you're talking about he's a [__] like
video AER or whatever right he calls me
up out of the blue acting like I haven't
talked to you in so long and I was like
I don't know when we ever did but and
I'm going to entertain this call and
then he's like telling me about the
projects oh I like this and this and
yeah and then like gets me in the
conversation hour and a half goes by and
then he asked me for this location where
we shot this uh cool Western uhhuh and
then I was like [__] mad after that
and I was like why why am I so mad I'm
like yeah that's why you called huh I
had if you just called me and said Hey
Joe that was a great [__] place can I
get get the can I get the location I'd
really appreciate that all right cool
but then I think that's a hour plus of
inauthentic conversation just to butter
me up so you could get what you want and
I'm like well also you must be around a
lot of ego Maniacs that won't give you
information unless you butter them up
true that's that's this town what if I
call you up yeah for like 30 minutes I
just verbally butter the [__] out of
your [__] right that'll be nice and
at the end of it I go that's it I hang
up oh
[__] that's the Long play don't trust
that either though you can't trust that
one year's time I call you with a favor
and I go hey that location though I need
the that the Western set would you think
there's something weird about that or no
as long as you separate it butter me up
for an hour wait 5 minutes days then
call me or start you you know what do it
the other way start with what favor you
want then butter me up for an hour let's
do that or
or butter Joe up for an hour hang up
call back in 2 minutes he forgot that
conversation already happened cuz Joe's
already in out of space and then ask him
for the favor ask him for the Wester
yeah all right got
it